es una propuesta transgresor a que las
mujeres han acogido con los brazos
abiertos el gobierno de españa' ha
presentado el primer proyecto de ley de
europa para que las trabajadoras puedan
optar por una baja laboral por dolores
menstruales con una reforma dentro de la
ley del aborto si una persona que es
mujer tiene una menstruación que le
impide e impide trabajar o estar
decentemente en un puesto de trabajo ya
que una menstruación fuerte pues puede
ser algo
muy movido si puedo decir eso pues me
parece perfectamente es común que
durante su periodo las mujeres sufran
fuertes dolores menstruales así como
síntomas como diarrea mareos e incluso
vómitos incapacitantes para el desempeño
de cualquier trabajo la situación es más
compleja cuando además son pacientes con
endometriosis una patología en el útero
que afecta entre 10 y 15 por ciento de
las españolas como en el caso de claire
band es una entrenadora personal que no
puede trabajar cuando tiene la regla
manning and colleges fui a tantos
médicos a tantos ginecólogos que no
encontraban nada a pesar de los exámenes
para que finalmente después de un año
alrededor de la navidad' de 2021 empecé
a desmayarme podía sentir que los
órganos vitales me fallaban y hay que
volver my major guns of work failing
main el lento diagnóstico y el
desconocimiento de la enfermedad así
como de los fenómenos asociados a la
menstruación son situaciones con las que
el gobierno de coalición de izquierdas
ha prometido terminar
a cabo ir a trabajar con dolor se acabó
en pastillas e antes de llegar al
trabajo y tener que ocultar que esos
días estamos con un dolor que nos
incapacita para trabajar el permiso será
pagado desde el primer día ilimitado
pero deberá ser prescrito por un médico
una propuesta que se espera que el
gabinete de gobierno discuta y apruebe
el próximo martes